[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome to the State House welcome to
your house the people's house my name is
Virginia Drew and I'll be one of your
tour guides and my name is Margaret
waterhous and we're very excited to
bring you throughout the building
today we look forward to showing you
your state house inside and
out I'm really excited to be able to
show you around our state capital to
show you our wonderful building right
now we're outside of the state house and
behind me is our building the people's
house when you look at the State House
you can see it's gone through some
changes over the last 200
years back in the day it was just a
two-story building the second floor and
the first floor were the only thing here
and there was no big Portico and that
great big wonderful golden dome that
didn't come until in the midst of the
Civil War so we had a very modest
building but a building that has stood
here for over 200 years during the Civil
War our legislators realized that we
needed a larger building and we wanted
to show that New Hampshire was here to
stay so they added on a third floor and
they put these big Granite columns up
front to make what we call the Portico
and above that great giant Dome was
added to the top of our state house
where it has stood ever since and when
you visit you can see that golden dome
from miles
[Music]
away on our lawn we have some statues we
don't have a lot of statues
but the first statue that was ever
placed on the front Plaza of the State
House was Daniel Webster Webster was a
great Statesman and he memorized the
Constitution he knew about our laws and
he represented New Hampshire extremely
well in Washington DC Webster also was a
lawyer and he took on some of the
biggest issues of the
day we have John Stark John Stark was a
revolutionary war hero who led at
battles like Bunker Hill in Bennington
and John Stark is very famous for New
Hampshire state motto Live Free or Die
for death is not the greatest of evil he
lawn on the left is John hail Senator
John hail I have to tell you I had never
heard of him when I first came to the
State House but now I have studied and
learned so much about the great Senator
John Parker hail his statue is here
because he fought for rights of people
for all people he was a great
abolitionist and he was one of the first
US senators to stand up in Washington DC
and say slavery is wrong slavery must
end those are the three statues right
here on the Plaza but just outside right
guarding the gates is New Hampshire's
one and only President Franklin Pierce
Franklin Pierce's statue was put up
years later after he served in
Washington DC representing our great
state the large Arch that many times
people come through to enter the
building is dedicated to New Hampshire's
sailors and soldiers as a memory of all
those who have sacrificed for New
Welcome to the New Hampshire state house
flags back in the day this room was just
a big wide open Hall the only thing in
the room were these white
columns this room long before it was
called the Hall of flags was called
Doric Hall it is the room where for over
200 years men and women have come into
this building they've walked past these
wonderful Doric columns made out of
solid New Hampshire Pine on granite
bases the eight columns in the center
have been here all that time but there
are two imposters in the
room this is one of them and if you
knock you'll hear the hollow tones
because the are plastic replicas
imposters in the
hall those columns were actually added
in
1969 this Hall later during the war was
where many of our soldiers came through
to go to the Adent General's office and
they were issued battle flags and the
flags went off to war with our New
Hampshire
men today we call it the Hall of flags
and it's a Memorial Hall dedicated to
all of New Hampshire's men and later
women who sacrificed their lives for
us what was left of the flags came back
here to this room the flags have been in
these cases for well over 100 years in
the Hall of flags we have 88 Civil War
battle Flags looking at the flags you'll
notice that some of them are not in
great condition some of them are
shredded and torn but some of them are
also in great
condition the flag bearer was in charge
of keeping keep the flag held up high
this was a way of communication because
back then there was no cell phones or
walkie-talkies on top of the flags there
are numbers and these are the regiment
numbers or the group numbers and we have
flags with the numbers 5 2 and 12 these
flags were all at the Battle of
Gettysburg the worst battle in America's
history we also have flags from World
War I and World War II you'll notice
that these flags are in much better
condition addition because at that time
the flags were not carried out into the
battlefield so New Hampshire's Hall of
flags is dedicated to New Hampshire's
veterans and to those Heroes who served
the role of Honor here lists the names
of
697 men and women just from our small
state who sacrificed for the people
during World War I significant to note
is the first woman to lose her life and
sacrifice in the military her name was
an Frasier Norton a woman from New
Hampshire and her name is on that plaque
below is our Congressional Medal of
Honor recipients many of those names
hail from the Civil War era but there is
an addition on that that role of honor
and Sergeant Ryan pittz from New
Hampshire had his name added in
2014 these were the bravest people who
received the highest military honor
there
is throughout the state house we have
over 200 paintings Harriet patience Dame
was the first woman hung on the State
House walls Harriet Dame was a very
brave woman and she was a civil war Army
Nurse Harriet Dame would go out onto the
battlefield to help wounded soldiers she
was a part of regiment number two during
this is our civil war mural this shows
the Battle of Gettysburg day three
looking at the painting you'll notice
the condition that the flags are in and
you'll see the scene that's happening
this is what happened at the Battle of
Gettysburg
[Music]
we're now in the Great Hall
Representatives Hall this room has gone
through changes over the last two
centuries back in the day legislators
sat on wooden benches and today they
have these cushy seats but some of the
things that have saved stay the same for
over a 100 years are the paintings on
the
wall the five large portraits on the
wall have been there for over a 100
years you all probably recognize the
portrait in the middle of the room
Washington to his right is one of our
most favored presidents of all time
Abraham Lincoln I have to tell you that
Abraham Lincoln's portrait is the newest
portrait out of the five up here on the
wall in the
1920s students just like you felt that
we should have a painting of Abraham
Lincoln on the walls of our state house
and so they did a fundraiser they
collected pennies because Abraham
Lincoln is on the pennies well they
raised enough money in pennies to raise
over $2,000 to help bring this painting
to the walls of the state house next to
link is his very dear friend we showed
you his statue outside it is John Parker
hail John hail also served in the House
of Representatives in this room he was a
speaker of the house and later did run
for president against Franklin Pierce
whose portraits over there Franklin
Pierce like his friend John hail was
also a Speaker of the House Franklin
Pierce was the youngest Speaker of the
House ever in New Hampshire's history he
was only 26 years old when he was in
charge of the New Hampshire
legislature and next to him is our dear
friend Daniel Webster Daniel Webster
never served in the New Hamshire State
Legislature but he had such an impact on
our state and he memorized the
Constitution and knew so much about our
Constitution that he is known today as
the defender of the Constitution
and what better person to have on the
walls here in Representatives Hall when
you look around the room you can see the
lovely high ceiling and right above us
is that great golden dome that was added
[Music]
War the house will come to water members
will pleas please be
seated here in the house chamber we have
400 state representatives on a session
day the room will start filling up with
our 400 members to become a
representative you must be 18 years old
and live in New Hampshire for two
consecutive years so in just a few more
years you can run for office and be
House Representatives have assigned
seats and the speaker of the house will
decide where they sit kind of like how
your teacher assigns your seat in
school Representatives only get paid
$100 a
year Representatives don't work here for
the money they work here to make good
decisions and pass laws for the people
of New
Hampshire on the arm of the chair there
are numbers and those numbers match up
to the electronic voting box the
electronic voting box has three
different buttons the white button is
the activation button but also takes
attendance just like in school the
speaker of the house has to know who is
here and who is not there are three
different ways that representatives vote
here in this room quite often they do a
Voice vote but sometimes it's hard to
decide if the yes or no was louder
question all those in favor say I oppose
nay no yeah the chair is not sure let's
there'll be a division vote there are
also division votes where they use the
electronic voting buttons there is a yes
button and a no button and on the
scoreboards it will appear how many
people voted yes and how many people
voted no electronic voting
Representatives will only have 30
seconds to vote and if you don't vote
within that 30 seconds the house clerk
will call you out in front of everybody
and ask what your vote is sometimes that
can be a little bit embarrassing the
house will be attentive to the state of
the
vote with 217 members voting yay 150
voting nay there's also a roll call vote
and on a roll call vote the
representative's name is attached to the
vote and you will find out how
Representatives
voted up above is a balcony and this is
what we call the visitors Gallery the
visitors Gallery is open to the public
and you would be able to come in and
watch your representatives voting if you
weren't able to make it there is online
convenience we are now in the Senate
chamber this room has been in use for
over 200 years you'll notice that this
room is much smaller and that is because
we have just 24 senators in New
Hampshire Senators also have assigned
seats and they sit by district from
district one who represents the North
Country all the way to District 24 Down
By The Sea Coast to become a senator you
must be 30 years old and live in New
Hampshire for seven consecutive years
Senators represent a lot more people
than Representatives they represent over
50,000 people but per the Constitution
they actually get paid the same amount
as Representatives $100 a year the
Senate President and the speaker of the
house they get paid a little bit more
money
$125 a year but they have a lot more
responsibility this room is much
different because Senators also have
desks and
microphones when the Senators wish to
speak the Senators actually have to get
the attention of the Senate President
the Senators raise their hand and go
like
this and if the Senators have a question
they raise their hand and draw a
question
mark here in the Senate there is also
three different ways to vote there is a
Voice vote just like in the house but
the division vote is different all the
yeses would stand up to be counted and
all the NOS would stand up to be counted
for a roll call vote the clerk will call
out each Senator by name and state if
it's a yes Vote or a no vote here in the
Senate we also have a visitors Gallery
you'll notice that it's much smaller
than the one that we have in the house
chamber but everyone is welcome as long
as we can fit you up there you can come
in and watch often times we have fourth
graders that actually come in and kneel
in front of all the
guests when you come into the Senate
chamber one of the first things you
usually notice are the beautiful murals
on the wall those murals are really new
to the Senate chamber back in the day
the room was very plain white walls a
few paintings every once in a while and
and the Senator's tables that was about
room later in 1942 a wonderful artist
named Barry fauler from Keem New
Hampshire he painted these murals they
were painted on linen they were painted
on cloth at his home and then brought to
the state house and glued to the walls
of the Senate where they have been ever
[Music]
so the Barry fauler murals all four of
them represent something that's
important to New Hampshire here in this
first mural is New Hampshire's last
Royal Governor John Wentworth along with
the Reverend Eliza Willock and they're
at the first graduation at Dartmouth
College and so that mural is to remind
us the importance of Education in New
Hampshire the next mural well here he is
again Daniel Webster but in this mural
he's only about nine years old he's
sitting on the floor of his parents
store in Salsbury and before him is the
United States Constitution I mentioned
Daniel Webster as the defender of the
Constitution well when he was in about
fourth grade he memorized the United
States
Constitution the mural is to highlight
our government in our constitution New
Hampshire was the first state to create
its own state
constitution the next Muro probably one
of my favorite shows a group of artists
Barry fauler painted himself into the
mural with some of his artistic friends
the man sitting with the ducks in his
lap that is Abbott the fogner and the
developed the protective color theory
today you know it as camouflage in in
fact this group of artists went to
France during World War I where they
introduced their protective color theory
and that is why it's called that French
name
camouflage the mural on the end there he
is John Stark putting on his coat ready
to head out to battle during the
Revolutionary War one of New Hampshire's
other firsts were we were the first
state to declare our independence from
the British and John Stark was one of
our greatest leaders in
1945 sitting in this room lawmakers
voted on our state
motto with John Stark's picture right
there before him one of the Senators
seated near here stood up and he said
this should be our state motto Live Free
or Die the other senators all agreed
with a loud unanimous vote they moved
that bill onto the house where they also
agreed and that bill then made its final
step like all of our state bills do
anything that wants to become a law has
to be voted by the senators and
representatives but it doesn't become a
law until it goes down the hall to the
desk of the governor and now we're on
our way to the governor's
[Music]
office here in the governor's reception
area are the more recent paintings of
Governors looking at the paintings you
can see that the governors choose where
they have their portrait done Governor
Jud Greg has Mount Washington in the
background Governor Merill has his
painting with the gold dome in the
background jeene Shaheen's painting is
done in the executive Council chamber
Jean Shaheen was the first elected woman
Governor we're now in the executive
Council chamber here is where New
Hampshire's Governors have been working
and meeting only since 1910 because our
governor's office is located in what we
call the new part of the building only
110 years old and around here that makes
it pretty
new on the walls are some of the
earliest governors of New Hampshire
including those from England Governor
Bernett governor beler and everyone's
favorite over there Governor
Dudley those governors we didn't elect
those governors they were sent here by
the king of England to rule over New
Hampshire and when they ruled over New
Hampshire they did whatever they wanted
so they could choose all their friends
to be judges they could put all their
friends give them all the best jobs and
pay them whatever they wanted do you
think the people of New Hampshire
thought that was a good idea oh no they
didn't and so today in New Hampshire we
have another special piece of government
it's called the executive Council
the people of your District oneth of the
state actually elect an executive
counselor also to represent them so if
your our governor is from the North
Country he can't give all the jobs and
all the appointments to people up north
or if they're from the Sea Coast Area we
have a counselor from that area every
one of you has an executive counselor
who represents your part of the state
and the people who live near you and
this room is where the governor meets
with his five executive counselors the
counselors actually sit in order of
where they live starting in district one
up in the north country and working our
way around the state down to District 5
in the southwest corner the governor
sits at the head of the table there are
times when the governor uses this room
to actually sign bills into law and then
we very often have many people in here
the day they sign the law for the potato
Bill our state vegetable the governor's
table was surrounded by fourth graders
this room is also where the governor
gives many of their speeches and you
sometimes will see that on television
with the governor standing at the podium
discussing things governor and Council
meet very much like the representatives
do they meet on a schedule but if the
governor wants anything to go forward
with the executive branch he needs a
vote of these counselors it makes it
hard but it also makes it so the
governors make the best decisions for
the people we're the only state that do
it this way when the governor goes to
sign bills into law the check and
balance has already happened because the
Senators and the representatives have
represented us and voted for that so to
sign a bill into law the governor can
have a wonderful ceremony and do it
right here or he could actually go to
the school or to the town where that
bill was first brought up one of the
most famous bills for my fourth graders
is the pumpkin Bill fourth graders from
Harrisville New Hampshire felt the
pumpkin would make a great state symol
as our state official fruit of New
Hampshire that bill went before the
house where they voted yes it went
before the Senate where they voted yes
and then it ended up on the desk of the
governor and the governor at that time
realized those students had put so much
work into this that he brought the bill
with him to their very school and signed
that bill into law right there all the
bills whether it's something fun like a
pumpkin bill or what should be our state
beverage or something really serious
like protecting our people of our state
The Bullying bill that fourth graders
helped bring forward they all go through
the same process with the same serious
weighing out of whether it's a good law
or
[Music]
not we are now in the visitors center
where we begin and end our tours this is
the room where we welcome guests from
all over the world all over the country
and we even welcome presidential
candidates to this room but our most
favorite people to welcome are New
Hampshire school children we hope you
enjoyed your tour and we hope to see you
[Music]